inflation rising food prices rising gas
prices we've all had to face this
reality at some point but is the answer
to rising prices raising chicken as we
found out that just might be a solution
with gas prices on the rise a recent
earth week poll reveals the inspiring
ways consumers are embracing
sustainability while also saving a
little cash customers are switching from
gas to battery-powered tools greenworks
has over 75 operated tools a tractor
supply a riding lawnmower battery
operated one has the same power as its
gas-powered brother but it can mow up to
2.5 acres on a single charge that mower
can save 2 000 over 10 years by
comparison to gas when it comes to
sustainability at home don't count out
gardening and yes even poultry farming
inflation is putting a squeeze on all of
us you and me so people are looking to
gardening and backyard poultry to extend
their budgets especially during the
pandemic we've seen more people look to
backyard poultry it's all about
sustainability and a great learning
experience and family fun one chicken
can lay 250 eggs in a year so with
organic eggs at six dollars a dozen see
this is a much better deal visit
tractorsupply.com